today I'm worth it fries why don't you
tell us what we're gonna do today and
address the kind of way
today I'm worried that we're gonna be
trying to three drastically awesome fry
it that pretty drastically different
price points to find out which fries are
the most worth the edits price we're
starting this episode here in Los
Angeles and then later on we're gonna be
going international oh I love it
we're gonna Montreal because we're doing
french fries but we didn't want to go to
France so I went to French Canada next
best thing that's how that works right
my name is Steven and I like to be even
the only thing that Rises Steven it's
even you know what I'm leaving bread
let's go eat some fries that's you
unleavened Devon hey I'm Stephen frets I
am the executive chef and co-owner of
top round roast beef tell us about top
round we do roast beef sandwiches
hand-cut french fries we make our own
ice cream custard our tagline is chef
driven fast food what does that mean for
you here we take the time to really
focus on the technique everything in
this kitchens mean this kitchen our
cheese whiz our fries there's a human
element to everything we do and that's
the way that we want it today we're
gonna be trying our hand cut curly fries
how do you get to the curly fries shave
I'm just realizing I've never seen a
potato turn into a curly fry it is the
machine that was made for us so we're
gonna put our potato in there so we're
then that's tight do your hand like that
and push hard there you go all of our
frying this kitchen is done in beef fat
beef fat is the classic way of do it is
it all comes down to one thing flavor I
think as a chef there's a lot more
flavor and beef back than in every day
of oil we finish them with fine sea salt
and serve oh I see on every table
there's this seasoning shake yeah it's
the same exact seasoning that we have on
the beef it's kind of our signature I
recommend putting it on the fries what
is the goal texture or really great
do you want a crispy fry on the outside
and then you want to be fluffy in the
middle that golden color is what you
strive for it people need to understand
that this is a live vegetable certain
times of the year you'll get a fry
that's more golden than a fried that's
at the end of the season that has more
starch in and will burn more you just
have to be aware of the difference in
the potato and how it fries oh right
what did you order from me Andrew you
have a concrete and I have a strawberry
shake cheers Stephen Cheers
oh yeah oh that's really good you should
try this it's really nice and like milky
you know like that whip printing that
Oreo okay we're not here for when I do
an ice cream okay boom rise my new
favorite thing on this show is when we
just say the same thing at the same time
ready
okay Brian [ __ ] okay look how fun that
is it looks like a shag carpet but a
potato no okay hey look looks like a
cursive beef lowercase a Cheers
incredible awesome it's surprisingly
fluffy yes I saw but probably the right
word Oh as a lunge indeed my bride have
it drew towel or shake on it yes I don't
know if it's because I know that it's
flavored in beef fat but it tastes
meteor okay delicious would it be
obscene to have a bride in some ice
cream oh oh oh no don't lose it that's a
really very delicious strawberry ice
cream on a beefy potato highly
recommended I was recently visiting my
filmmaking friend and he was like to be
ahead of the curve do what others won't
and that is what they're doing
with curly fries again fresh potatoes
from I know coconut and beef fat I like
the way you say potato potato how do you
say potato she say potato no you're
saying it wrong
potato you have to enunciate you sound
like an Lord of the Rings poet a toes
can you try something rusty you want to
go bite for bite on that so for it
and sadly weren't eating as long at the
price this is a soft and delicious this
is crispy and delicious this smooth and
delicious and is so oh yeah we're back
know throw some of that on their hair
boom roasted you yeah roast beef to
Montreal which we're going the next
little old Canada we've traveled here
because we've been enticed by a certain
dish that we're gonna get to later in
this episode but before we get there you
might recall when we had our bagel
episode we learned a little factoid
about bagels in Canada in Montreal
everything bagels are called all dressed
bagels
so we decided to treat ourselves to a
little all dressed action of our own oh
yeah
give one to this guy I'll take one for
myself
[Music]
were you just singing the where are we
off to now
a little restaurant called love love
we're gonna try some vegan food we had
on vegan french fries first the last
place is definitely not gonna be vegan
at all but this place we're doing kimchi
fries let's try
[Music]
I'm Stephanie oh that I'm the chef here
at love restaurant in Montreal what kind
of restaurant is love we're specialized
in botanical cuisine so we're serving
vegetarian and vegan food today I'm
gonna make the kimchi fries that famous
kimchi fries was that your idea
first of all right okay and then where
did it come from I really love fermented
foods in general it's really good for
your gut it's good for your system all
the vegetables from the kimchi's are
grown in Quebec it's all organic and
it's fermented here I really wanted to
place kimchi on the menu I didn't want
to put it somewhere that it will scare
customers so much so with the fries I
was like everybody buys fries it's like
super comfortable and I think our
clientele is a little bit Monsieur
Madame chairman like everybody so it's
probably very new to them
what was that expression you use
Monsieur Madame Simone mister Madame
everybody like Joe Schmo
Joe Schmo anybody and then we add the
kimchi to it after that we make the
sesame male i thickened our house-made
soy milk al e with a blend in the
Vitamix of miso see touch sugar garlic
rice vinegar sesame oil then we just
squeeze it on top of the tip kimchi and
then it's ready to eat what makes the
fries like the perfect medium for that
kimchi having this umami flavor to to
the fermented foods that's a good
compliment you know the taste yeah
such a cute cutting board it's like a
ping-pong paddle
you make a awesome ping pong sound Wow
every time we come to a restaurant we
immediately grab
take towards something heavy the
restaurant does not care about
whatsoever but they do care about this
cucumber black pepper kombucha cucumber
black pepper kombucha so I'm talking
about cucumber kombucha tastes like
delicious pickle brine yeah if people
Brian tasted good sorry for the people
Brian logo sorry pickle Brian does taste
good
this is like a toned-down beverage
version of pickle brine alright let's
dig in you want to go fry first I first
always fry first delicious dried potato
a little mayo on mine I got a little bit
of my own body
yeah a little preview for the main
feature here yeah now I'm gonna go for a
forkful cuz I want to get all these
flavors in my mouth at once oh yeah a
whole bottle I'm making a mess my turn
my turn
Jimmy Cheers
oh yeah I can brush this for sure this
is not what you would think is being
first of all is usually when I'm eating
kimchi it's with delicious meats yeah
this Mayo Aeolis has to me thing it
feels like I'm eating something very
meaty and the potatoes are like perfect
better for all the kimchi non eaters non
enjoyers out there you just need to
understand that it is a pairing for
delicious hot savory food yeah a hot
crisp french fry yeah
kimchi is perfect with that I don't feel
like crap not for eating these Raj is
like that's hard to say with fries
and I've had cheese fries that taste
less creamy and delicious than these
kimchi fries day right I thought those
that was cheese at the beginning hey
chef how do you say that saying again in
the soup madam to the moon
what's your my damn to Lomond who did it
better
the records show chef pointed at me
every time we do this in any language he
beats me I don't understand Monsieur
Madame to a limo okay that was not a
very good he says I want ratatouille FRA
fact Thomas Jefferson is actually
credited for bringing the French fry to
the States
really he was serving as the American
minister to France in the 1780s he was
like this is delicious
let's bring that over he referred to
them I can't speak French but eponymous
did today free days we're just gonna
bleep that out and we'll get an actual
french-speaking person yes boom dude f
he taking our booty to Tosh or potatoes
deep fried while raw in small cuttings
just adding up to his list of accolades
being on independence big on writing big
on declaring he brought the French fry
over and we thank you sir
so you may be wondering how did we come
up with $100 french fries well we're
getting 15 pounds of codeine
we're like munch free all for munching
mmm I invest more in sorry
you ready yeah I mean not at all but
sure hi I'm Casa colon or bootie Villa
Montreal we prepared a nice meal for you
today it's called the heart attack a
nice meal called the heart attack it's
what we're known for we get groups of
two that come and challenge themselves
to who can eat the most out of the heart
attack seven years that we've been open
only one man has done it one man and it
took him 22 minutes to do it that is
unbelievable so tell us about poutine
bill what kind of establishment is this
instead of us creating our own menu we
like that clients create their own
proteins we have endless amount of
toppings whether you want to be vegan
whether they want to meat lovers we
focus on great ingredients fresh product
and we let the customers get very
creative what is poutine oh wow poutine
is funky fast food with a twist
fries lure there were lots of cheese and
lots agree what you put on top is what
makes you different from everyone
growing up you a preteen watts that's
where poutine will actually started
whatever my mom made for dinner the next
day was a poutine hello whether it was
lamb spaghetti beef it turned out to a
protein of the week the heart attack is
a monster poutine it's the biggest one
in Montreal ten vegetables chicken bacon
ground beef hot dogs sausages steak a
traditional poutine is made with a
cheddar curd but we infused it with
mozzarella so we get a little bit more
of the stringy effect so when you pull
the cheese out it's delicious and it's a
double layer poutine what we do is we
put a layer of potato have the
ingredients and a layer of cheese you
know we build another poutine on top of
that one which becomes a monstrosity and
we cover it with gravy at the end and as
you can see it's shortly it's fantastic
is this like a fork and knife type of
situation it's a fork inertia trait you
should have a bib at the same time
because it could become a little bit
messy wrong color for poutine we take a
second to just appreciate the majesty of
this this is yeah 15 pounds and I was
born I was 10 pounds and I thought that
was big yeah it is big for a baby very
sorry you're Steven let it commence
[Music]
potato we delicious solid that fry is
exactly what I wanted in these fries a
good base starchy but ready to just like
soak in the other juices I'm gonna roll
up my sleeves
definitely a sleeve rolling dish may the
best competitor win
[Music]
up until now I wasn't convinced that
gravy belonged on fries
oh maybe blowing on everything we do I
have three different meats in one go you
didn't even have a fryer in your fork
going in look at this thing
I feel like a giant that's just eating
the earth like a mouse trying to eat
human food I think that's just how our
personal outlooks on my farm
you're digging quite a hole there I've
reached this second layer of cheese kind
of like how you can tell how old the
fossil is based on what other materials
have laid on top of it there's no way
like human ate this in 22 minutes
let's footage i watch adjustment oh I'm
gonna make the claim that he's not human
we need to turn this into an unsolved
episode oh do do do do do do do do wait
what is that music a man claimed to have
a in 15 pounds of poutine but how could
he do it in 22 minutes go and then Shane
goes well don't say he's an alien what's
happening I think we got the meat
Delirium you make a dent and then it
caves in on itself so do you like
poutine I'm really loving this yeah
the great thing about it is you never
get bored you can just make your own
routine in this poutine right now I'm
feeling really meaty but then later on
my ah too much bacon so I go more fries
whatever you want to do you can just
assemble that literally in this massive
pleasure 15 I think you're winning right
now
oh yeah so if you actually wanted to
finish this how many people would you
bring 17 people I don't know I can't oh
yeah we've barely dodged it oh do I see
the bottom yet no it's been 20 minutes
in the time that we finished two small
dents of food a man came in and ate the
entire thing that seems impossible for a
human I want to just take a nap
[Music]
can I feed you one final bite no I can't
please put the cards away mmm what's
called poutine you put English
I'm just work off the fries okay it's
just you can try it but you won't
those are now part of your body
permanent know which fryer which
placement was most worth it to you those
fries at protein Ville could feed an
army
that was insane value 51 pounds 100
dollars if I was in high school and on
the football team that is the food that
I want to eat but why were the winner
goes to top round the fact that you got
a little curly action on that that's
just fun fries are about fun and the
curly fries is the funnest fried of them
all my hope that winner goes to can be
fight that love it was just delicious I
felt great after I ate them Adam what's
your worth or winner so that ends things
for us here in the Montreal is a
delightful trip you need to go to
Montreal one shoe my dumb shoot
kutiman kutiman you like that because I
said it first time I did that where I
feel second no nobody remember Dez cuz I
couldn't remember how to say it either
hey check out our Instagram it's new
it's at BuzzFeed worth it you guys there
oh oh yes